un monstre de flamme et de fumée
apparaît rapidement après le décollage
nous volons à une quinzaine de
kilomètres au nord-est de cette île
celui qu'on appelle communément le feu
172 et le plus gros actuellement au
Québec et l'un des plus gros au Canada
il couvre une superficie de 34000
hectares et continue de grossir vers le
nord heureusement à l'opposé de la ville
grâce au vent favorable près de la
célèbre rivière Moisie envoie des
milliers d'arbres calcinés et une
pourvoirie autochtone de Maliotenam a
été ravagé
au sol à 8 km des flammes des pompiers
venus en renfort de Québec les vies et
saguenaient arrosent la forêt sans
relâche ici c'est pour protéger une tour
de communication et on va appliquer des
quantités d'eau pour venir humidifier le
sol pour s'assurer que les endroits sont
bien protégés dans le cas où ce que le
l'incendie progressait vers cette
emplacement parce que le feu n'est pas
encore maîtrisé et les pompiers savent
bien que ces flammes ont parcouru 4 km
en direction de la ville en une seule
nuit vendredi dernier lorsque les vents
soufflaient vers le sud très optimum
pourquoi parce que au niveau des
infrastructures tout est mis en place
pour les protéger au niveau citoyen tout
est mis en place aussi advenant le coq
ça irait pas bien on est capable des
évacuer dans un délai quand même très
raisonnable quelques 5000 résidents de
Sétil et de maliothénam ont d'ailleurs
dû quitter leur domicile il y a
maintenant quatre jours et ce matin les
autorités ont prolongé leur évacuation
d'au moins une autre journée c'est sûr
qu'on a du monde qui sont anxieux aussi
dans toutes les feux on essaie comme là
ce soir je pense qu'on va donner un peu
un genre de conférence sur l'anxiété
dans les pires des scénarios envisagés
sachez que les effectifs nécessaires
sont là alors c'est ça qui nous rassure
aujourd'hui principalement deux types de
langues que vous allez utiliser sur
parce qu'en plus des pompiers l'armée
s'apprête aussi à intervenir à cette île
des dizaines de militaires qui ont eu
droit aujourd'hui à une formation
accélérée d'une journée une bonne
semaine demain matin on prend nos ordres
auprès de la surfeuse on se lance on va
être 150 probablement sur le sur le
terrain ils apprennent à manœuvrer les
tuyaux et à retourner les terres brûlées
les militaires apporteront un important
rôle de soutien aux pompiers et ils sont
motivés les pompiers ont une état
d'esprit ou un mindset qui est similaire
aux autres quand ils se déploie en avant
c'est pour aller combattre le feu un peu
à l'image des Forces canadiennes nous
quand on se déploie en avance pour aller
combattre en plus de toute cette
entraide les nord-cotier s'apprête à
recevoir un nouvel appui et c'est le
plus important la pluie elle commence
cette nuit et devrait durer trois jours
ici Jean-Sébastien IEN Cloutier
Radio-Canada s'est-il